what are you up to now you're still
making music of course of course making
music uh
always will make music but been focused
on a lot of other things started a
company called indie amplify another
company called maps um and i'm managing
the dudes that just came in here and
went crazy and murdered ocd ocd osmond
benjamin chris rivers anakin michael
minnelli a lot of dope artists i'm
managing now and then um yeah just focus
on indie amplify and dropping music
because i love music just because you
have the luxury yeah yeah indie amplify
is like a that's a great idea yeah
because a lot of people who are
independent
they don't know
where to get like access to like the
easiest things like some people are like
i don't know how to get my [ __ ] on tick
tock with an influencer or i don't know
how to get a feature how do i even begin
to get a feature right or how do i even
begin to get some advice facts even like
uh
you do like uh consultations yeah
and um really playlisting all sorts of
also if you're trying to get your [ __ ]
on it's like a one
stop shop for any independent artist who
has a serious like you know
anyone who's serious about their craft
is trying to invest in their [ __ ] like
they could go there and really kind of
pick and choose like what they want to
do right yeah it's like all the label
services at your fingertips basically
where it's like you could book a feature
from an artist you could get uh
consulting from like aces on their core
days manager um you can get consulting
from adam ivey who's a huge youtube
marketer you can get consulting from all
these people you can get playlisting you
can get uh educational resources
content creators social media
influencers everything to really boost
your career and we've had a lot of dope
success stories where you know people
cop a feature for example somebody
copped a feature from me and then
the next thing you know chanel west
coast is trying to jump on the remix
with this person not that that's the i
was gonna say is that a good thing
that's not that that's the end-all
be-all but what's dope it's just
respected you know west coast but you
can get seen by
so many people from working with other
bigger people so you could book dizzy
write for a feature you could book
devonterrell futuristic uh all these
different people for a feature yeah
because you kind of have like
been so self-made throughout all these
years
and you had to figure out a lot of this
for yourself yeah um
what like what sparked the idea to like
bring it all together it literally was
every same [ __ ] you probably go through
where everybody's hitting you up like yo
can you link me with this can you link
me with this can you do this so it was
like after i started like learning the
playlist in game and i built a
spreadsheet a playlist i was like people
started hitting me up like how you want
all these playlists so then i started
playlisting people then people were like
how are you getting reactors to react to
your stuff and it's just like all the
homies already knew right so then i'm
like i'm tired of
middle manning every single thing so i'm
just going to build a website for people
to get everything so when i had that in
mind i was just like okay what resources
do i really have and it's like oh
features music reviews consulting
youtube reaction videos all this
different stuff and so i just put it on
one site and we take a 20 commission and
everybody if anybody asks me for
anything somebody sends me a link to
listen to their music in the amplifier
indie amplifier music review right here
i'm not listening to your music for less
than 100 bucks boom there it is period
and so that's kind of what i encourage
everybody else to do as well and not as
the owner but as the artist on the site
i made 150 bands last year just from
people booking me for music reviews
consulting and features wow so you can
really live off of it and i wasn't even
our top selling artist who's your top
selling artist um we had crypt do hella
bread on reactions justina valentine got
requested for a ton but she doesn't
accept a bunch of them right so like if
she would have accepted all of her she
would have made like two 300 bands